[Musique]
bonsoir à tous sera vide vous retrouver
pour un nouveau numéro de mode d'emploi
votre magazine consacré à l'emploi et à
la formation professionnelle focus ce
mois ci sur l'apprentissage la voie
rapide pour s'insérer sur le marché du
travail tout de suite le sommaire
l'apprentissage a de plus en plus de
succès un parcours de formation en
alternance entre le travail en
entreprise et le suivi des cours à
l'école
les explications les détails et des
conseils sur ce type de cursus à
retrouver dans ce magazine
rencontre avec antoine martinez ce jeune
apprenti est actuellement en terminale
bac pro maintenance de véhicules
alain fort pas de guyancourt il effectue
son attaquant roumain garage à achères
témoignages
à suivre enfin plusieurs opportunités de
contrats d'apprentissage sont à saisir à
saint quentin en yvelines
retrouvez les dernières offres à la fin
de ce magazine est tout de suite on a
que yann le gal bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes conseiller communautaire délégué à
l'emploi et à l'insertion
professionnelle avec vous on parlera de
l'apprentissage à saint quentin en
yvelines et du rôle de style ou et 16,25
la mission locale
oui on va en parler dans ce magazine
mais on va commencer avec ce chiffre 300
2380 c'est le nombre de contrats
d'apprentissage signés en france en 2018
une augmentation record de 7,7 pour cent
par rapport à 2010 est dans les yvelines
à la rentrée 2010 8,9 1865 jeunes sont
en apprentissage et leur one google est
ce que vous ressentez cette attractivité
pour l'apprentissage sur le territoire
il y avait vraiment une forte demande
une forte pression de l'état ça c'est
une première chose mais tant mieux tant
mieux vraiment ça va plutôt dans le bon
sens et nous alors en tout cas entre
président de skyway et nous qui agissons
sur le bassin des deux communes on voit
bien que ça bouge et on voit bien que la
filière certaines filles rentrent
tensions sont fortes de membres et puis
des filières commence aussi à bouger un
temps un peu plus l'oreille en tous les
cas nous sommes très attentifs et des
orientations que nous avons sur les
jeunes que nous recevons qui sont un
petit peu dans la tente
eh bien on nous fait chier vraiment sur
l'apprentissage à ce jour on a 150
depuis début d'année 150 jeunes qui ont
été fléchés skyway au niveau
l'apprentissage est justement
l'apprentissage qu en quoi consiste ce
type de formation quels changements ont
été apportés par la réforme sur la
formation professionnelle
comment trouver son entreprise pour
l'alternance c'est la séquence trois
questions à sabine barea les
développeurs apprentissage sur le
territoire sud yvelines
l'apprentissage c'est une façon de se
former différente où on va alterner des
périodes en entreprise avec des périodes
en centre de formation le centre de
formation ça s'appelle un cfa centre de
formation d'apprentis
ça va permettre d'apprendre la théorie
en cfa et on va faire la pratique dans
l'entreprise actuellement l'âge c'est de
15 ans à 29 ans qu'on peut se former en
apprentissage est le plus gros avantage
de l'apprentissage c'est aussi bien sûr
qu'on va acquérir de l'expérience
et grâce à cette expérience on va tout
de suite trouvé du boulot à la sortie
sept jeunes sur 10 en ile de france
trouvent un emploi à l'issue de
l'apprentissage
il ya énormément de gros changement
c'est à dire qu'on attend tous la
maintenant en janvier ce qui va vraiment
se passer puisque la réforme va enfin
s'appliquer en janvier l'apprentissage
j'étais avant confié aux régions il est
maintenant confier à l'état donc avec un
grand organisme national qui s'appelle
france compétences qui a été créée pour
gérer l'apprentissage il y à une aide
qui a été prévu pour le permis pour les
apprentis donc 500 euros pour aider le
jeune à passer son permis dès qu'il
apprend qu'il ya le droit et qu'il est
majeur le salaire qui a été un peu revue
c'est à dire qu'ils ont été augmentés de
30 euros les plus jeunes quand euros net
par mois parce qu'on veut vraiment
favoriser l'apprentissage
vraiment ne pas hésiter à se tourner
vers le cfa
le cfa a régulièrement des appels
d'entreprises etc
il travaille avec tout un portefeuille
d'entreprises et souvent je vois le
jeune un peu isolé dans son coin qui
revient pas vers le cfa et le cfa est là
aussi pour coacher le jeune l'idéal
c'est de se déplacer même dans son coin
c'est à dire où on habite on va faire le
tour des petites entreprises qui
pourraient travailler dans le domaine
qu'on recherche
l'entreprise a n'attend pas du jeune qui
sache déjà faire le métier parce que
l'entreprise elle est là pour le former
mais qui puisse au moins parler un petit
peu de ses motivations
qu'ils sachent un petit peu se présenter
et qu'ils aient un comportement correct
bien sur le savoir-être c'est hyper
important
erwan lequel un chiffre que à retenir de
cette séquence
sept jeunes sur 10 en ile de france
trouvent un emploi tout de suite après
leur apprentissage
c'est un moyen de lutter contre le
décrochage scolaire mais aussi contre le
chômage des jeunes alors très clairement
mois depuis 10 ans j'ai ma délégation
sur l'emploi la station depuis quatre
ans mais depuis dix ans je tiens ce
discours rien pour sortir du marasme
économique français il faut passer par
la voie de l'apprentissage c'est
incontournable
il faut regarder les modèles allemands
suisses comment il fonctionne en france
on a tellement tellement décriée
l'apprentissage que maintenant nous
payons un petit peu le revers de la
médaille mais mais la sortie de cet
enfer 70%
c'est sur l'île de france dans d'autres
régions en à des taux beaucoup plus fort
que ça et tant mieux et tendu de toute
façon c'est gagnant gagnant
le jeune à une formation il est rémunéré
et un diplôme à la fin de sa formation
est le chef d'entreprise a à l'issue de
cette formation un futur employé qui n'a
pas besoin de former pendant quelques
mois puisque déjà il est opérationnel
si will taurine vraiment justement vous
côtoyez souvent les chefs d'entreprise
dans votre délégation sur le territoire
de saint quentin en yvelines que ce soit
les grands groupes ou même les pme
qu'est ce qu'ils attendent d'un apprenti
ces chefs d'entreprise à les attendent
beaucoup
mais tant mieux ils attendent surtout
une ressource supplémentaire ils
attendent aussi
qu' il y ait une vraie transmission des
savoirs de la part de de même pour les
grands comptes en tout cas d'écart et
c'est auprès des jeunes
et puis quand retour ces jeunes-là
apporte aussi une fraîcheur un nouveau
regard
il y à un modèle économique qui est
quand même assez sympathique parce que
ça a un coût moindre qu'un salarié
et puis ça permet également parce qu'on
vient dire précédemment c'est aussi dans
la continuité de service et puis
d'employabilité pour pour ces jeunes
après ce qu'il se dit aussi c'est que il
faut pas galvauder un petit peu cette
cet état d'esprit des jeunes parce que
il y a aussi des jeunes qui on rencontre
des périodes difficiles et c'est une
issue l'apprentissage était une belle
issue le savoir est sabine la reine l'a
très bien expliqué il faut vraiment être
très attentif avec le savoir est donc ça
les chefs d'entreprise ils sont très
attentifs et pour le coup c'est aussi le
l'autre aspect de l'apprentissage dont
le recrutement c'est que les jeunes qui
n'ont pas été suivies pour le savoir
être et bien sûr retrouve sans résultat
et justement le savoir est ce vous avez
un impact à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
dessus puisque la mission locale ce qui
les 16-25 accompagne les jeunes
justement dans la rédaction de leur cv
comment se présenter à un entretien là
aussi vous agissez là dessus sur le
savoir être des plus jeunes
lorsque alloués mais pas que il ya club
fasse beaucoup d'acteurs agissent en ce
sens c'est la clef actuellement
enfin comme j'ai dit précédemment les
chefs d'entreprise à la limite
le cursus antérieures savoir s'ils ont
un niveau de 3e seconde terminale peu
importe le savoir être oui essentiel
c'est essentiel il ya plusieurs filières
sur saint quentin en yvelines qui sont
concernés ain par l'apprentissage et
notamment l'automobile sur saint quentin
en yvelines un campus est dédié à ce
secteur
il est situé à guyancourt et a ouvert
ses portes en septembre 2010 huit parmi
les différents centres de formation
d'apprentissage situé sur ce site il ya
linfo re passer dans cette structure qu
antoine martinez poursuit une formation
en main
dans ce véhicule regardez dès que les
coudes et de clé à cliquet une des clés
spécifiques les bronches voilà une
partie des outils de travail d'antoine
martinez ce jeune yvelinois est apprenti
en mécanique automobile
une semaine sur deux ils travaillent
dans ce garage en alternance avec sa
formation au programme de la matinée la
révision une voiture accompagné par son
maître d'apprentissage alors mental tu
ton juste en face le trou de la goupille
il a fait la vidange juste avant là et
donc du coup on a remis le on a remis le
bouchon antoine martinez suit sa
troisième année de formation il passe
actuellement son bac pro maintenance des
véhicules en entreprise il acquiert le
savoir-faire le gérant de ce garage lui
transmet aussi les normes de sécurité de
qualité et le soin des véhicules du
client pourra mettre des housses dans la
voiture se fera plus propre
depuis 11 ans cyril martinez dirige ce
garage il accueille souvent des
apprentis pour les former et les
embauches et ensuite un avantage non
négligeable pour ce chef d'entreprise
en fait il est formé un peu un peu à
notre manière un peu comme on a envie
que de devoir travailler
en mécanicien chez nous et point positif
c'est que déjà on peut alterner on peut
être un entre deux semaines on est payé
on est payé comme un comme un salarié
mon adhésion à des des salaires fixes
pour les apprentis quand il n'est pas en
entreprise antoine martinez dans son
centre de formation d'apprentissage la
fort parce situé sur le campus
automobile de guyancourt ce matin-là il
a cours en atelier sur des véhicules
objectif réaliser des diagnostics ont
créé des pannes sur les voitures et par
rapport à ces panneaux on donne aux
jeunes comme si on était on se
transforme ce ce jour-là en clients
entre guillemets pour le jeune en disant
ma voiture à tel problème et le jeune
recherche savane
au fur et à mesure des procédures et on
le guide n'est trouvée la première fan
déjà enfant pas grand chose
c'était quoi la première femme
c'était un flic été coupée entre l'a1
entre la sonde et calculateur on apprend
à utiliser des outils qu'on n'a pas
forcément en entreprise
on apprend à utiliser s'utiliser
multimètre ski et les hostiles aux scop
en 2019 la forte à écueil 213 apprentis
allant du cp au bac et bts entre les
cours classiques et les activités en
atelier l'objectif est d'acquérir des
compétences théoriques et pratiques
l'apprentissage a est une est un format
de formation qui est très parlant avec
une insertion professionnelle assez
importante de l'ordre de 80 70 à 80%
un jeune en fait sortant du centre de
formation
obtient un travail dans les six premiers
mois alors je me antoine martinez va
poursuivre sa formation jusqu'à la fin
de l'année et un examen final son projet
professionnel à terme ouvrir son garage
ou devenir mécanicien pour le sport
automobile
erwan le gallo voit que ce campus avant
ya plusieurs cfa implanté sur son campus
c'est une réussite ça a ouvert ses
portes en septembre 2010 vite c'est une
réussite on peut le constater déjà c'est
vraiment une réussite qui les visitent
et c'est alors il ya tous les pans de
métier donc ce secteur là c'est vraiment
une réussite parce que on voit bien que
ils ont des niveaux de matériel
pédagogique de haut niveau et c'est ce
qu'a dit le jeune sam et en écho aussi
par rapport à ce qu'ils font en pratique
dans des garages qui ne plaide pas des
moyens eux d'avoir ce matériel de
technologie que l'on découvre aussi des
innovations plein d'innovations
jérôme le gal merci beaucoup d'être venu
sur notre plateau le conseiller
communautaire délégué à l'emploi et à
l'insertion professionnelle et avant de
conclure cette émission une offre
d'emploi de pardon de contrats en
apprentissage à l'hypermarché de
carrefour à l'espace saint quentin de
montigny le bretonneux
c'est un poste de boulanger destinés à
un jeune préparant un c ap vous serez
amené à préparer les produits de
boulangerie gérer le rayon et préparer
les commandes pour les clients autre
offre direction elancourt au quartier de
la clé saint pierre la boulangerie
maître pierre recherche un pâtissier en
contrat d'apprentissage l'apprenti sera
amené à travailler de 7 heures à 14
heures du lundi au vendredi pour
acquérir les compétences d'un pâtissier
professionnels pour candidater vous
pouvez vous adresser ce courrier à
florent est à l'adresse suivante il
s'affiche en bas d'écran heads @ sfr.fr
et pour déposer vos candidatures
n'hésitez surtout pas à vous rendre sur
site à aller voir des marchés les
entreprises de directement sur place
et puis vous pouvez aussi découvrir
d'autres offres en apprentissage mais
aussi des offres d'emploi sur le site
sky emploi.fr il s'affiche en bas de
l'écran
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
nous avoir suivis et à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]